I'm going to warn you right now I'm too
tired to be nice okay so I did a video
just a couple of days ago sort of
expressing my current general thoughts
on the DC movies and sort of the
pessimistic state that I am in and have
been pretty much continuously since I
walked out of the theater acting Suicide
Squad so um I'm in a worse place now and
I'm gonna kind of rant it out um this
was kind of set off by the news that Ben
Affleck is no longer directing Batman it
just got me thinking about the whole
thing again and upon reflection now I
honestly think the best thing that could
happen right now is that we scrub this
entire thing we start from scratch when
I do my last video I said that I have no
hope that would say wonder one it's
gonna be any good but I would like it to
be I'm not there anymore
I wanted to fail I actively want Wonder
Woman to fail I wanted to botch the
character I want it to be a mess I want
it to not do nearly as well I would want
justice Lee to be justly that kind of
cluster that BBS was just with some
really shoehorned in lousy awkward jokes
so they can claim that they were lighter
in tone this time when really they did
nothing structurally to change anything
I want people pissed I want these things
to suck so that Warner Brothers has no
choice but to scrub this and start over
because even if Wonder Woman is okay
decent not terrible look I'll say this
if Wonder Woman is great maybe I'll be
in a better place maybe I think that's
maybe the one thing that can pull me out
of this but again
hope that that's going to happen hi zero
faith that it's going to happen
so if Wonder Woman is okay does decently
or at least makes a decent profit then
they can afford to have Justice League
Soccer's ago worked at one time but
we'll keep going
we'll keep plugs ended and they'll just
keep trying no do we need to they need
to stop making good money they need to
start losing money on this I mean you
look at what Sony has been planning
before amazing spider-man to
underperform so badly now amazing
spider-man to kill made seven hundred
million dollars worldwide but it was a
severe under performance and it for Sony
to completely replay in the strategy
because before that movie wrapped up a
theatrical run they were looking at a
sinister six movie a venom movie I'm an
amazing spider-man 3 obviously and a
spin-off without may being a spy during
the Cold War and the movie amazing
spider-man 2 was not a good movie and
people were very vocal about that people
were very vocal about their at best
skepticism about funny was what Sony was
doing it Sony to their credit when um
pump the brakes on this and reset and
we've now got a new spider-man why do I
feel so far as a better spider-man we've
got spider-man Home Coming which Marvel
is had a hand in and I am hopeful for
now if a spider-man homecoming suck
that's not going to change my argument
either way because I would still rather
they just take another crack at you know
clearing the deck and starting over
rather than they stayed the course on
what they were planning cuz what they
were planning was insane and everything
I'm seeing and hearing about what Warner
Brothers is planning is insane a Black
Adam movie they still haven't moved the
flash off from March next year release
despite the fact that they're doing a
page one rewrite and they still have no
director Ben Affleck has been saying for
like a year
now don't worry I'm going to direct the
Batman and but we're not going to start
until I know the script is good I
wouldn't direct it the script wasn't
good guess what he's not directing it
what should that be telling us and
please understand this is not an anti DC
thing this is an anti Warner Brothers
thing because I believe that the
infection like you would Warner Brothers
specifically and not just the people
handling DC I don't like what they've
got going with Harry Potter either
they're already planning for five
sequels to fantastic beasts and where to
find them and I went to that movie based
on the title thinking oh this will be
fun and it'll be you know like it's
almost like Pokemon and they're
collecting the pieces like oh no and
here's your wizard Hitler I didn't go
there for was a Hitler and now that's
going to be the main focus they're
already planning five sequels and let
whatever others in entertainment entire
corporate structure is infecting
everything and it's not only just
limited to movies if you don't know some
of the crap that Warner Brothers video
games of vision as pulled I'll be real
quick on this what the sub that they
pulled would be Batman Arkham games has
been atrocious if you are a gamer you
might already know about this if you're
not you might be on well everyone loves
those games yes everyone loves those
games when they work Warner Brothers
guys go back to Arkham origins their PC
release on that game was so screwed up
and it had so many glitches but they
wouldn't fix it and the reason they
wouldn't fix it is big and they said
this flat out we can't fix the bugs
because we're too busy making DLC if you
don't know video game turns DLC is
downloadable content meaning extra stuff
that they were going to then sell to
customers to add on to the game that
they wouldn't fix they were more
interested in making more stuff to sell
you than fixing the thing you already
bought the release of Arkham Knight a
later game in that same series was so
bad on the PC which was ported over with
very short notice by a third-party
company it was so bad they had to
retract it issue refunds to everybody
when they rereleased it for pc a few
months later it still barely worked
Warner Brothers as a company does not
give a and look I know they're out to
make money every company is out to make
money but some companies are out to make
money while still preserving their
properties while still maintaining the
integrity of the franchise's of their
intellectual properties Disney does this
honestly really really well their
corporate is heck but they're also
incredibly careful and defensive and
aware of the impact and what people
think and feel about their properties
and they want to be sure that people
feel a very specific way about the
things they make all water brother cares
about is that you shell out the money
they don't care if you liked it they
don't care if you're excited for more
once they have your money they don't
care and since money is the only
languages they understand that is the
language we need to start speaking with
I am honestly and no you know what no
I'm calling it right now unless the
reviews are positive on the Wonder Woman
movie unless the people tell me flat-out
no they got it right it's finally great
I'm not going I will not give these
people my money anymore because money is
the only way at language they understand
and if that's the only language they
understand that's the language I'm going
to speak in you won't get my money
anymore Warner Brothers I'm not giving
it to you
not until you change what you're doing
you change your behavior and you show
some semblance of understanding that you
are pissing people off with what you're
doing for to the complete disregard for
these properties and instance you do
these token little BS things they say oh
well Geoff Johns is gonna work on the
things now and he'll guide this kid not
overseeing this why could you got him
doing a ton of them and stuff he's still
running comic books on top of this
you've got him working on these scripts
and supposedly ahead and you overseeing
the whole thing no no man can do that
there's a reason that Kevin Feige over
at Marvel is only doing that job he's
not also writing scripts writing comic
books no is only job is to oversee
and make sure that things go smoothly
you claimed that you gave Jeff jobs that
position even if you did there's no way
he can do it while still doing this
other stuff which means that's more BS
it was a it was a bone you through it I
shut off the fan point well I'm not
shutting up I love these characters I
love Wonder Woman I love Batman
I love Superman I'm okay with Aquaman
but you're screwing this up and you
don't care I want this stuff to fail
because they want it fails maybe then
finally you will look at what you're
doing look at how you are damaging the
very things that earned you your
paycheck and you will reassess and you
will think more carefully before going
for five movies deep on something you
aren't even sure anybody wants and I'm
pretty sure this is about as angry as
I've ever gotten on this show and I
don't want it to be the norm but it's
what I'm feeling today
so this is what you get you don't have
to agree with me this is just a point
that I'm at right now but if you can
give me reasons to be hopeful that
aren't just oh come on give them a shot
try one more wouldn't it be nice for one
- oh no no give me something tangible
give me something - if you have it
please give it to me I don't like being
this angry I really don't so drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe follow me on Twitter and
council of geeks check out the counselor
peace podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned